a stowaway from Peru Paddington Bear had
nothing more to his name than a floppy
hat good morning
really tipping it down isn't it a
suitcase and a tag around his neck to
help him search for a new home in London
but he found his way into the hearts of
generations of children the person who
held Paddington closest to his heart
was Michael bond Paddington's creator
died this week at the age of 91 bond was
working as a cameraman for the BBC when
he came up with the marmalade loving
character inspired by a teddy bear bond
bought as a last-minute Christmas gift
for his wife and named after the train
station bond used for his daily commute
Paddington made his debut in 1958 a bear
called Paddington would launch the
series that sold more than 35 million
books as Paddington himself says things
are always happening to me I'm that sort
of bear Paddington's Adventures later
continued on television and in 2014 on
the big screen with a Hollywood sequel
do this fall my dog who's nine now was
recently
I think this is purely because of the
new film that's just come out where
you've got real-life characters as
opposed to animation Paddington's become
as much a British icon as the Royals you
can find a statue of him in London's
Paddington Station
a few weeks before his death bond
released the latest installment of the
series
Paddington's finest hour and according
to the publisher Paddington's adventures
will continue and that's good news I
loved Paddington Bear when I was little
and as a reminder I mean to get another
one a new edition it was the first
stuffed animal I bought my oldest
daughter that Paddington Bear with the
tag boys please look after this bear
thank you